I'm going to say it, dude. When you, when you have fresh sheets,
not only is that sleep the best. Yeah. That's it.
That's the best wind you'll have in like a month in fresh sheets. Dude.
You gotta wait. You wait, wait, wait. You weren't like disgusting.
What are you? Sorry, you can say, yeah, you're like winking onto your sheets.
Like, are you like cheesy on site?
On the napkin when you put them on so fresh,
the room smells nice and it feels comfortable. You're like, ah.
That was the biggest they had us in the first half I've like ever had on this
podcast. Cause I was going to be like, yeah, I know exactly what you were
saying. You don't like that. Come on,
Jack off my bed as well. It's also great that,
you know what you said, if you want to say that the women were like, yes,
I agree. But same thing. Same thing.
Climax in the bed. Fresh sheets. All same thing.
No, like I L I love fresh sheets. I hate the process of getting fresh sheets.
Like, okay. Like putting on bed sheets, you've seen
quite well. What's your setup
kind of has like you look at Connor's like gaming setup. It's like perfect.
Everything is like optimize. I didn't, then you see his bed. And it's like,
one of those,
like Reddit reacts to like some of the worst gaming setups I've ever seen.
It's it's, it's like, it's like a $2 bed set up.
Like you just have like a towel on your know.
There's literally nothing in my bedroom except a bed. And there's like,
literally nothing. Whereas like I was from a bedroom,
I just sleep in there and do anything else.
And that seems like broken isn't it it's broken as well because I bought the
cheapest one, Amazon when I moved here, because know moving's expensive. Right.
And it was so expensive that I was like, I gotta go.
Cause I regret it because I bought a $200 bed.
And that was the mattress combined. And this awful. All the Springs of the beds.
It's literally, as you're talking so much about like, yeah,
why would you buy a $20 headset when you can just buy a hundred dollar one?
You get your money.
I had that philosophy. But again, moving kind of like distorts your,
your price range. Yeah. You're spending like, you know,
I got to put down like a full K deposit on this. And the flights are this much.
I'd pay shipping for my PC. Like I'm spending a lot of money. I'm like,
I'm kinda kind of losing a lot of money. I've got to start saving costs.
I can't buy a 10 K bed frame. So I bought the cheapest one on Amazon,
which I regretted within about two weeks. Um, actually, no,
immediately when I built it, because building,
it was a pain in the because I could tell when I was building it, I'm like,
Oh no, this isn't even like budget plywood.
This is like the throw away plywood that they would use as like the foamy.
I don't remember seeing the exact bed frame.
He bought an Amazon and it was like two and a half stars.
And that's when I knew that.
Mistakes for me, I.
Just wanted something and I wanted it now and I regretted it so much.
But anyway,
what happened was the most ghetto thing that I have is that I'm actually using a
bed sheet as like a mattress cover. So.
What happened was right. How do you stretch that over it? Okay.
Actually with a lot, like the power of Zeus, I'm like, I'm putting this,
I'm like.
The red sea back together. When I'm trying to put these bedsheets to zip.
Yeah. Just all around my mattress. Oh, you around your mattress.
Your mattress.
Like spot, I guess. Right when he's kicking the guy,
I like doing that to my mattress.
You have to do that every time you wash your mattress as well. So.
What's your bed sheet. I started washing my bed sheet as well.
Yeah. So I have to strip this thing out and then wash it back here.
I feel so sorry for your bed, man.
It's very stretched. So what happened? Okay.
But also I do avoid that annoying thing. This is a very, like,
this is like the only plus in this and I'm gonna go into the meeting negatives.
The only plus, right. Is that, you know,
that annoying thing when you're sleeping in the bed sheet comes off in the
corner. Yeah. You can never get it back on unless you actually get off the bed.
Yeah. I hate that. That sucks. I don't have that issue.
[Inaudible] I can see like the benefits of it because like the,
the best bedsheets are the ones that are like.
If I see wrinkles on that, that's, that's such a, that's like instant, you know,
because sometimes you'll wake up and on your body. You'll like, have like,
I'm just like, what the is that?
I do have a backup bedsheet, which actually that proper,
but I refuse to use it unless I'm desperate because I love this one.
And I like even putting it back on while.
Turning your mattress, it's all been bad. So here's how.
I ended up with a bed sheet as my duvet. And it goes all around my mattress.
I fully put it all around my mattress and zip it off. Yeah.
So when I moved here, I went to NITECORE, which is kind of like Japanese, Ikea,
which I think we mentioned before I go there. Right. So I buy,
I buy the pillows, the pillow sheets, you know, I buy the duvet and I,
I go to the staff member and I ask him and like,
I'm making sure I've got Google translate, man. I'm like Dubai. Or like,
whatever, that cold blanket, whatever I did not say like futon.
I mean, don't say futon. I'm like, I'm showing him, I'm like this.
I even showed a picture. I'm like, Oh, this trough, which one is this?
Then like broken Japanese with Google.
Translate was like, Oh no problem, fam.
I got, you pointed me to this. I buy it. I get home.
It's futon. And he saw me by the futon, another fruit on it.
Wasn't even in the same section as well.
So that's where I was confused when I got home. So I'm like, wait,
this isn't a different section. Why do we have two different futon types?
What is this? So.
Two futon covers. So I have the bedsheet and then I have the mattress.
So I got home and I needed to sleep. So I'm like, well, it.
It's going in one way or another, like, it's going over my bed. I haven't gone.
Helped me the first time getting up. Yeah.
This is a [inaudible] you get that on yourself. So
I thought,
I just assumed that you got to do me now. I've I've.
Mastered the technique to Hazel. I do get it off. It's easy.
Cause like, it's like, it's like your body wants to get off.
It's like letting a pig out of clothes. That wants to come up, get it back on.
Right. Okay. First of all, this, this is the setup.
I flipped my mattress to the side. So it's upright.
And I like pull over half my flip it upside down the other end, pull it up.
And then this basically what happens is, is that it's up to here, right?
So this is long horizontal. That's right. I've got a,
basically forced the together. Like grab it together and hold it.
And it hurts my hands. Cause tight.
I got to like slowly pull a little bit by little bit. And if I let go,
it all goes back. So I have to keep grabbing a little bit and zipping,
grabbing a little bit and zipping. It's a pain in the.
Why don't you just get a duty on the world's largest clone on a dude,
just get a proper bed.
You know what? I love the firmness of it. Like I love how tight it is around me.
Let's get a bed sheet and just, you might as well, not even have a bed sheet.
Why, why?
Like there's a difference between having no bed sheet and having a phone.
I sweat like a. I need a bed sheet. Right? It's like a thousand yen. I dunno.
I've kind of gotten like you straight kinda like
literally made a spreadsheet, trying to optimize cooking.
And he can't even buy a bed sheet.
Because then I got to optimize that. It's another thing to optimize.
I'm sick of it, man. Well, too fast that,
that whole optimization with the Uber eats was just to justify to myself why I
can have like pad Thai three times a week.
So like, I like,
I like the final result of cooking and clean bedsheets, but like, Oh,
I like having to change your Duval. Like did you find it a nice,
like fiddly as thing ever to like take the duvet off and like putting it back on
and having to make sure every, every corner is perfectly situated for you.
If you have a zipped up wall, not, not, not the bed sheet,
the actual blanket. Yeah.
Oh, that's easy. Cause the, the ones that Japan, big brain,
they come with the holes at the end. So you can just flip it up inside, out,
grab the thing and then yeah. That's what I want.
Well, you could do that. Yeah. That's what I've done it ever since I started.
You turn it inside out. Yeah, I do that. And then you look like a little ghost.
You put it over you. Yeah, I do that at the ends of the, the futon.
And then you just like flip it over and then it.
Yeah. And then shake it down. But like, for me, like,
I don't know if hotels do speed running a hundred rooms. Like,
I don't know if my like,
cause I think I have like my nightmare where my duvet is not the
same size as my blanket. It's slightly bigger.
So I always have like left a little bit of fabric on it triggers me so much,
man. I hate the ones. I hate the ones like our old dovey.
Well, it was like the perfect size. But the problem was is that it would,
the duvet inside would move around.
So like one end of the duvet would just have like just scrunched up.
So let's just try and pull it over. It's just, and I'm just like,
with what's the dude. They go.
That's why I think you are most likely to have a mental breakdown when you're
doing your bed sheets. So putting out Dubai office, I that's,
that's why I hate it, man. I hate it. I don't know what it is about Sheetz on,
but what? It just doesn't work. You're like, it. I just want to cry.
Why won't it work? Why won't it work this my day,
going to work in like a hotel,
like lodges and like ski fields and stuff. And I had to do that every day.
So yeah.
So basically like shovel out of the drains and then you gotta go do that. Yeah.
So I had to, I, that sounds like my nightmare at first I hated it. I was like,
Oh, there's this 30 rooms in this hotel that doesn't seem too bad.
Five rooms. And you're like, man. I want to go home. Like,
like just around with the dude. Just like
[inaudible] I actually have a mental breakdown.
If I just do like five sheets in like one hour, I would actually be like, no,
no, I don't think life is. Yeah. I'm like, I'm not getting paid enough.
I brought it.
I would actually [inaudible]. I'd rather shovel and like get shouted out. And
don't five do in the row, man. So now I'm just used to it because
I've lived through that Vietnam war.